we have a clearer picture of the events
leading up to the shooting at YouTube's
California headquarters and police are
defending how they handled warnings
about the shooter nassim Ogden shot
three people at YouTube Tuesday before
killing herself police say family tips
about Adams anger at the company did not
include that she would turn violent John
Blackstone is outside the YouTube campus
in San Bruno California John good
morning good morning well the CE
amalgams father says he alerted police
on Monday that she'd been missing for
two days he says the family made it
clear that she had a dispute with
YouTube / censoring her videos and that
she could be headed that way but police
say there were no signs of an impending
attack she was very calm very
cooperative when police say they found
the seemed odd I'm at around 1:40 a.m.
on Tuesday she was asleep in her car
about 25 miles south of YouTube's
headquarters after discovering the car's
license plate matched that of a missing
person Mountain View Police Chief max
Purcell says officers contacted autumns
family on the second conversation we
received information that she made me in
this area because she had a dispute with
YouTube police say there was nothing to
suggest that dispute would turn violent
family members who asked not to be named
spoke differently one year as Ogden
continued driving north police say she
stopped at a gun range before arriving
at YouTube's campus that's where
officers say she walked through a
parking garage and into a courtyard
before opening fire with a 9-millimeter
handgun she purchased legally what
security is in place at YouTube and did
she have to get past any security to get
to this courtyard so we know the area of
the of the campus where she entered
we're still determining whether what
security measures she had to navigate
through - to get to where she was at
have you worked with YouTube on security
I think yes we've done that we've
trained with with YouTube regarding
critical incidents there is security on
site ATF agents in Southern California
spend as much as 14 hours searching
homes
Ogden's family members for evidence
Ogden's father spoke briefly to
reporters i'm sorry i can't believe it
youtube says it will be increasing
security at all its offices worldwide
the two women wounded in the attack here
have now been released from the hospital
the third victim a 36 year old man
remains in serious condition Gayle
all right we'll be thinking about him
thank you very much John